(audience cheering)
- Possibly coordinate a tiny bit.
- Yeah, well, I'm not gonna lie,
they told me, you know,
the set's gonna be decorated for Christmas
if you wanna look Christmassy.
And I was like, well, I kind
of already picked this dress,
but maybe it's kind of that
pastel fifties Christmas.
- This is Zimmerman.
- And then I saw you and
I was like, "Oh, stop it.
"Stop the presses."
- Do you love,
did you watch White Christmas growing up?
- I didn't watch White
Christmas growing up,
but I mean, it is iconic.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And, I mean, that was iconic.
- Oh my gosh, I love that movie so much.
- [Anna] It's beautiful.
- Yeah, what's your Christmas go-to movie?
- Well, I guess Elf kind
of became the thing,
but Scrooged and Home Alone,
and you know, those, yeah.
- Home Alone, very famous in my house.
- Classic.
- I have kids.
So what holiday traditions
do you look forward to,
like, with your family?
- Well, I actually
just started learning to
make cocktails and stuff.
So like, my new tradition is
like around Christmas
I'll make French 75's.
Do you have French 75's?
- What the heck, no.
- But when it's Christmastime,
I think they're usually made with gin.
But around Christmastime,
I make them with cognac.
And maybe this makes me sound bad,
but I did ask to have some French 75.
- Oh, I wanna try it.
Oh, I didn't know it was happening.
- They just appeared as if from nowhere.
- No.
(audience clapping)
Hysterically so,
I was so concentrated on
this performance earlier,
I didn't even know this
was happening. (laughing)
- I love that.
- [Kelly] So I love this.
- I love that for us.
- What is in it?
I love this for us.
- It's champagne and cognac
and like some bitters-
- Merry Christmas.
- Cheers.
Merry Christmas.
To your beautiful gown.
- I feel so classy right now, y'all.
- That smells good.
- Doesn't it feel Christmassy?
- Yeah.
- I like a mulled wine.
- I love a mulled wine.
- Me too.
- I love any excuse to walk
around with a mulled wine.
- Yeah. Casually.
- If there's like a like a farmer's market
with cheese or something.
- Christmas markets.
I love going to those.
- Oh, suddenly I'm in a Hallmark movie,
and I'm one of those girls
that holds her mug like this.
(audience laughing)
- Just cozy like.
- I have long mittens or
something in this fantasy.
Meanwhile, it's LA and I'm in sweatpants,
but that's how I feel inside.
- Do you get into New Year's,
or are you like an at
home, like this is a long-
- New Year's is so much pressure, right?
It's that same kind of
like Christmas anxiety.
It feels like such, like forced fun.
I usually just kind of hide out.
- You feel like you have to have
the greatest time in the world.
- Greatest time of your
life, or you failed,
and you suck as a person.
- I'm such an extremist in general,
and I either, yeah, I go all out.
Like I'm trying to win some
award for New Year's Eve.
Or I do nothing, and
I'm on PJs with my fam.
- Well this year a friend invited me to
a party that's like a theme party.
And so I was like, oh,
I'll do a little costume.
But then it turns into like
a competition in my mind.
- Oh, who's gonna the cooler costume.
- Like who's gonna have
the coolest costume.
So now I'm like on Amazon
and Etsy every five seconds
going like, okay, if I
pair like the red glove
with the gold rings.
And now it's like become a whole.
It's like the Christmas mantle thing.
Where like I don't have
like much of a creative-
- [Kelly] So this is the thing.
- Like visual outlet.
So now I'm like hyper-focused
on having the best costume at this party
where nobody needs me
to have a good costume.
(audience laughing)
- Let's talk about the new
movie that is so intense.
It's called Alice, Darling.
And this role is pretty personal.
I was saying it, I was like,
I remember us having a conversation.
I don't know if it was the
last time you were here?
- I know. I was like, is
this okay to bring up?
But I was like-
- Totally for me.
Like, I mean, it's wild
because the first time
that I was on your show, whatever it was,
a year and a half ago, or whatever.
And it was a couple months before
I went and made this movie.
And I was so excited to be on your show,
and you were such an incredible host.
And then during the commercial breaks
somebody said something that like
I ended up talking about what I was
going through at the time.
- We were both going through
like kind of devastating breakups.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
Not a thing you wanna have
in common with someone.
But yet we did.
- But hey, we bonded.
And I realized like at that point
I was just coming out of it
and I was realizing like,
it was so hard for me to
like not talk about it.
And I'd spent so long-
- 'Cause you're still working it out.
- Not talking about it.
That then it was like
the floods gates opened
and suddenly I was like,
oh, I'm trauma dumping on Kelly Clarkson.
Oh God.
- That's what everyone does.
I mean, I do that too.
It's like you don't know where to put it.
And so that's why my girlfriends
probably heard me say the same things
over and over and over again.
Through tears, and laughing hysterically.
And just, you know, back and forth.
- Yeah.
No, but I-
- It's hard.
It's like your way of working through it.
- Totally.
And it was one of those
funny things where we were
kind of joking about, like,
we were like really da da da da.
Like talking, comparing notes, whatever.
And then like we were
coming back from commercial,
and it was like, all right,
performance of a lifetime.
Nothing's wrong. Here we go.
We're on TV. It's all fine.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And yeah, so the movie is about
psychological abuse and emotional abuse.
And really the power of friendship
in the way that you can get through things
if you have the right
people in your corner.
And, I mean, I know that
that's how I got out,
and how I like started my recovery.
And yeah, the movie was
like so personal that
there was a point where I was like, oh,
I don't know if this is too
soon to be doing this role.
- To like bring you back.
- Yeah.
But I had I think like six months
between getting the script
and starting production.
So I had some time to
kind of grapple with it.
But, it was really cathartic.
- Do you find that it helps though?
Because I wrote a whole record,
and it's like I wanted to get out of it,
but I also wanted to get it out.
And it just wasn't all out.
And I just needed,
I just wanted to almost like,
in order to cross the bridge,
it's like you have to handle
all the things on the bridge.
You know?
- Yeah.
No, I think,
it's funny because I I don't
wanna suggest that like,
oh, there's a scene where
I cried about this thing
and I'm healed now.
But the process of making the movie
was really healing, because like-
- You're getting to experience
through a character.
- It was so fascinating.
There was a point where I,
early on the director was like,
"Oh, can we just grab
like a a moment of you
"where you're like lying in the hammock,
"and maybe you're reading a book."
And without thinking, I was like,
"Oh, I would absolutely
go out to the hammock
"with the intention of reading a book,
"but Alice wouldn't be able to read it."
Like, you're stuck in fight or flight,
and your brain is on this
loop and you can't think.
And you might try to read that book,
but you'll get like a paragraph in.
So I think I would just be like
staring into the middle distance,
unable to to do anything but try
to figure out how to fix
what was going on in my life.
And it was easier for me to look at Alice
and go, "Oh, that's really messed up."
Because it was so much harder
to look at the fact that
I know that from my own experience,
and that's really messed up.
So it was a really fascinating process.
- I love that this movie addresses that.
I love that your character addresses that.
I love that it addresses
the whole kind of process.
And then it ends up, you know,
your friends pull you, not pull you out,
you have to pull yourself out.
But having that, you know,
I just learned this thing from somebody,
but having that kitchen table.
Having your kitchen table
of friends around that,
that's your support system.
That's like, it's important.
- No, and the friendships
in the movie are flawed,
because the people are flawed,
because we're all human flawed.
But it's really beautiful the way
that they just keep showing up.
And I think that's one of
the hardest things to do
when someone that you love is suffering,
is to just keep showing up
even when they're not okay.
And to not invade and control and fix.
- Not try and fix it.
- Yes.
And like it's, yeah,
such a radical act of love
to just be like, "You're not okay,
"but I'm still available
to you and I'm still here."
And that was like really
one of the things that got me
through the last couple of years.
- It's a project you're gonna
probably remember forever.
Just because of the
personal experience as well.
But when Anna was doing
press for Alice, Darling,
I have to, there is no
segue, it's just funny.
- But that's okay.
We're talking about a
serious thing, but it's okay.
You're wearing glitter, it's great.
- I'm wearing glitter and sparkles
while talking about emotional abuse.
- As we should.
- I think that we have
a clip of this though.
We have to see this.
Okay. Show it.
- [Woman] Never know when you're gonna
get stuck in an elevator.
- [Anna] Did you say open up the hatch?
- [Woman] Everybody watch your head.
I can't believe this is happening.
Are you (beep) kidding me.
- [Man] Come on. We got you.
- [Anna] It's a good thing
I'm not wearing a short skirt today.
- I know.
- It was my worst nightmare.
You're obviously in an elevator.
- Yeah. So we got stuck in an elevator.
This is the first day of press
at the Toronto Film
Festival for Alice, Darling.
Yeah. A bunch of us got
stuck in an elevator.
And at first like the elevator jolts,
and you're like, you all make
a little joke about like,
"Can you imagine if we got
trapped in this elevator?"
And then it was like I was in Die Hard.
I was like, they pull you.
'Cause I thought, you know-
- Great Christmas film.
- Even though they call
the fire department,
you're like, oh,
they're gonna like pry open
the doors or something.
But we were actually stuck between floors,
and we had to do the thing of like
getting pulled up through the hatch.
It was very exciting.
It was like the most action
star thing I've ever done.
- [Kelly] Is this before
or after your press day?
- This is before.
This was like at the beginning of the day.
So I sat down to start doing
the first press junket for Alice, Darling.
And every journalist that
came in to interview me,
I was like, "Oh, I'm so sorry I'm late.
"I was just stuck in this elevator."
And da da da.
And all of them just thought like,
"Oh, Anna's funny."
So she's doing like a bit.
And the more that I was like,
"No, you don't understand."
- And then that drives you insane.
- We just now got pulled
out of the ceiling
of the thing of the
elevator by firefighters.
And they're like, "She is so funny."
(audience laughing)
She is really committed to this bit.
She is too funny.
- You can just say you're late, girl.
Oh my God.
That's my worst nightmare, by the way.
And I always make that joke when I go in,
just so it won't happen.
That's what I literally do,
to psych, to just trip up the universe.
Like, "Oh, wouldn't it
be funny if it happened."
And then it didn't.
- Well, it didn't work for me.
- Yeah, it didn't work for you.
I shall not say it anymore.